okay so what we're going to do today is
something quite different
I've never done it before we're going to
take Brady's cheap Casio watch it looks
like this we're going to try and make it
gold my favorite element
so what we have here is a contraption
that Neal made for evaporating metals so
what we have is we have a chamber vacuum
chamber and then we have in air two
electrodes and then the goal is going to
get really hot Gold is an element that
has really excited people for thousands
of years and one of the reasons is that
it's one of the very few metals that you
can find in nature as the metal in the
countryside in the right place you can
find lumps of gold and once or twice in
human history people have found really
large lumps of gold weighing a kilo or
more the Gold's gonna melt
a very high temperature eventually the
gold atoms are gonna start to come off
the gold hopefully we're gonna get a
nice gold coating on the watch it's
gonna look like a yeah expensive watch
Gold is a very unreactive element it
doesn't react easily with oxygen or most
of the other elements and therefore it
can exist in the environment under
conditions where most other metals would
combine with oxygen or some other
elements to form minerals so what we're
gonna do here is we're going to test the
whether or not the watch can withstand
the vacuum and so we're gonna put it
into this chamber before we put it into
the vacuum chamber over here because
that one has a turbo pump on it if the
watch does explode it might ruin the
torval so we're gonna risk this one
first
Gold is quite a large atom because it's
down near the bottom on the periodic
table and so it doesn't form very strong
bonds and it is forming strong bonds
that makes chemicals or makes elements
reactive so we're applying the vacuum
male to the watch it all seems okay at
the minute doesn't seem to have exploded
still work it is with styling a pressure
of 0.1 millibar metals look like metals
that is they have been the
characteristic Sheen shininess because
of the electrons in the solid are so
called delocalized that is the electrons
aren't attached to one atom but are
essentially shared by lots and lots of
atoms and in order to get this effect
you'll only need a very very thin layer
a few atoms thick 1020 atoms thick and
it already looks shiny and you can
hardly see through it so what I have
here is a little piece of gold that
we're going to put into the bolt in the
vacuum chamber and we're going to heat
it up to over a thousand degrees trying
to get it to melt too to evaporate you
don't take you don't need an awful lot
of gold to actually get a gold covering
on the gold colored covering on your
watch so actually it's gonna be very
thin covering of gold nano meter level
thickness gold like other elements in
chemistry goes through fashions the
famous chemist Michael Faraday in the
nineteenth century discovered that you
could form very small particles of gold
in water to make a solution which was
called a colloid where these tiny lumps
are so small that they don't settle out
so even after years the liquid is still
colored and in the last few years the
last 10-15 years people have suddenly
discovered that gold can be used as a
catalyst for quite a few different
reactions some of them quite simple like
carbon monoxide CO reacting with oxygen
to make co2 which is a reaction that
sometimes quite difficult to catalyze
and gold catalyzes it very well put my
little bit of gold into the onto the
bolt there we take
I'll put my little bit of gold onto the
bolt here in the milk
so this is a really high vacuum now I
think we're almost ready to crank up the
currents between these two electrodes
gotta heat up that bolt in there where
the gold is sitting up and we're going
to evaporate the metal onto the watch
temperatures going up and up now what
slowly turning up so the gold is heating
up can't see it melting point yet we
might need a little bit more heat it's
very difficult to find out how much
precious metal is mined because the
people who do the mining keep very quiet
about exactly how much they get out some
of the elements like rhodium are mined
on a very small scale perhaps 20 tons a
year of metal even though millions of
tons of rock come out platinum and
palladium are at least 10 times more
than that 200 400 tons a year and gold
is about another 10 times or so I think
and in a platinum mine gold almost comes
out as an impurity they mined the gold
even though they're looking for the
platinum but they get obviously quite a
lot of profit from the gold okay so the
gold is melt in I can see it melt in
here in the vault
Gold is completely liquid now so what's
happening now is the gold is boiling
away on the hot surface the atoms are
coming up here depositing on the walls
of the chamber and the watch is in the
way here so all that these gold atoms
that evaporate from the boat hit the
watch and hopefully deposit here give us
a nice thin gold film on the outside of
the watch I've had very little gold I
don't have a wedding ring all those
you've seen from our videos I am married
because gold can react with mercury and
it goes silver then and it spoils the
rings though you can polish it off so
I've never worn a ring and I don't have
any gold jewelry at all so you probably
can't see it
well on screen well what's happening
here is I can see the gold and the boat
is boiling away vigorously we're getting
evaporation here we could see I could
see hopefully you can see on screen
those goals depositing all over the
window here as it evaporates off the
surface off their boat but there's a
shadow here where gold hasn't hit the
window because the watch is in the way
and there's a couple of metal bars here
of course in ancient times the
alchemists were searching for gold what
they wanted to do was to try and convert
cheap metals like late I think the
reason they chose late was because lead
is heavy and dense like gold they wanted
to transform these cheap metals into
gold so they would become rich or even
better so they could sell the process
there was already the start of chemical
engineering selling the process to kings
and rich princes so the rich princes
could make gold you see the inside of
the window okay so see we've got a nice
gold film here on the inside of the
window so we definitely got some gold
evaporating the famous physicist Isaac
Newton was very keen on alchemy and
although his work on gravitation
mathematics was brilliant
his work on alchemy was rather more
misguided okay so here comes to watch so
let's see it's the front of it got brown
gold it has
and it's made a bit of a mess on the
front of the watch and I think it got a
bit hot and it seems to have melt at the
window on the frontier watch so we've
got a gold film here on the outside here
watch but you could see there's gaps in
the gold so you can see here there's a
little silver bands and that's where we
clip it on for the holder to keep it in
place